All of the samples we've
tested on Android Wear so far.
I've designed to be used for
a very short period of time.
If you run an app like this and
let it sit for a few seconds.
Eventually the watch display
will enter ambient mode and
the watch will switch back
to the default watch face.
You're watch activity
will be destroyed and
the user will have to
restart it again if needed.
So what do you do if you want to keep
an app running on the display for
a long period of time?
Such as showing the number
of steps while on a run.
One option is to grab a Wake Lock and
keep the display on.
But that will keep
the watch fully powered up,
draining the battery very quickly.
So, that's not a good way to do things.
The proper way is to use
a feature called always on mode.
This mode allows your app to control
what is shown on the watch screen
while the watch is in ambient mode.
It works very similar to a watch face,
in that the power usage of the display
and processor is kept to a minimum,
saving power.
You should only refresh
the screen infrequently, and
try to avoid doing any processing.
Later on in this course,
we're going to discuss watch faces.
Which run all down a watch and
it's the default to show when
nothing else is running.
But always on mode here is useful for
activities that run for
an extended period of time.
Where you want the watch to
go into ambient mode, but
you don't want it to run 24
hours a day like a watch face.
Here's the documentation that you
can refer to for more details.
Let's work through an example of how
to add always on support to a basic
wearable sample.
So let's create a new wearable project.
File, new, new project.
Use the defaults.
Make sure you create a wear
project with a min SDK of 21.
And we'll leave everything as is.
Now that the project is ready, open up
the Wearable Android Manifesto XML file.
We need to add a dependency to the
Android Wear Shared Wearable library.
The shared library is needed for
backwards compatibility.
So that older Android wear devices
that do not implement always on,
can still run your application
as a regular activity.
You need to request Wake Lock
permissions in
the AndroidManifest.XML as well.
Make sure you add this
to the phone app too.
Since wearable permissions must always
be a subset of phone permissions.
We need to have this here as well
to make it install correctly.
We also need to go to
the wearable build.gradle file.
We also need to declare our
targetSdkVersion to being 22,
since this is the first API release
when Always-on is supported.
In your build.gradle,
you also need to make sure that you're
including the wearable
support library correctly.
You also need to make sure you
include this new provided entry.
Which deals with some other
dependency issues when you want to
do release builds with proguard.
But you don't need to worry
about that right now.
We use the plus here to grab
the latest versions but
you can specify an exact
version if you want.
At this point, you should be able
to build and install everything.
You won't notice any differences yet but
at least you can check you did
everything right up until now.
Let's go and modify our activity so
that it can stay always on.
Click on the activity here.
Modify the activity so
that it extends WearableActivity.
You need to call setAmbientEnabled
to indicate that you
want to keep your activity
running in ambient mode.
Instead of going back to
the default watch face.
You then need to override
the onEnterAmbient method.
Which it's called as the watch
is going into ambient mode.
You can implement whatever
changes you want to your UI.
You need to present
a much simpler UI here.
So you should turn off
any unnecessary details.
Reduce the colors used and
keep the number of pixels
eliminated to a minimum.
Now let's set the TextView, so
we can when we're ambient or not.
Next, override the onUpdateAmbient
method to receive system delivered
ticks every minute.
This is useful if you want to show
an updating clock in your UI.
Which is important since the watch face
is not visible when your app is running
like this.
Finally, you override
the on/exit ambient method.
Which it's called when the user
touches the watch display.
And when we need to restore
the users interface back to normal.
So we need to undo everything
we did in on enter ambient.
Also, if you need to query this
information, you can call isAmbient.
To find the current state of
Ambient mode for your activity.
Although you shouldn't need to do this
if you track state in the previously
overwritten methods.
So let's now start up our app and
observe it in action.
The screen is in ambient mode right now,
and you can see that
shown on the screen.
when you touch it,
it wakes up in interactive mode.
You could slide the app away
if you wanted to as well.
When you do the palm gesture,
it goes back into ambient mode and
our app stays running on the screen.
And you can see the color and
size changes that take effect as we
switch between the different modes.
Finally, if you want to see
a more complex example.
We have a full sample demonstrating
how always on mode works.
That you can look at as well.
So go to File, Import Sample, and
search for Always On to find it.